i wanted
i wanted to ask you this um in the same
way that police brutality has always
been around
except for now we have phones that can
record it as it happens right it's not
like this is a new thing this is
something that's always existed
um it's just easier to see
what's actually happening i feel like
a lot of um trump becoming president
emboldened a lot of people who were
already racist
to just be more outward with their
racism yeah
i would almost argue though that that
started when obama became president
yeah it's not his uh it's not obama's
fault
but i just feel like when the black man
became president
you s that's when oh yeah people started
to lose their [ __ ] mind and really
show their true colors
unequivocally absolutely but here's the
thing though
there's so i get that question all the
time people will ask me
sean is police brutality actually worse
or is it just
social media and technology and the
answer is well both
every study shows that police brutality
actually is
worse and we're now able to film it
document it share it tell those stories
but we have more cases of police
brutality year over year over year
we have more hate crimes in america now
than we did
five years ago and 10 years ago so hate
is rising
police brutality is rising and we have
the tools to share
and talk about it so it's not it's a bit
of a misnomer
and i hear that i heard i heard will
smith say something very similar to what
you said kev was saying like listen
we've always had these problems that's
see that is true
but the problems actually are getting
worse
it's not just that we're seeing it more
every metric and every study i've ever
seen
shows that these problems are getting
substantively worse
and and we now have the tools to be able
to tell it and share it
so it's kind of both and in that sense
that
it does feel like it's getting worse
because it is
but it also feels like it's getting
worse because we're now inundated with
information about it every single day